uh gentlemen uh congrats on being part
of this series which I know is going to
be a huge hit
um what do you think it is about Taylor
Sheridan because everything he touches
turns into like something that people
want to watch and you know um I'm just
curious what do you think it is about
his writing and obviously taryn's winter
as well Taylor's uh Man Taylor's an
outlaw he writes Outlaw characters you
can't help but want to watch these guys
want to root for them all their
struggles all their conflicts I mean he
writes Outlaw gold
hell or high water sicario Creighton
Yellowstone now this Terence winter
Sopranos Boardwalk Empire it's a
deniable sort of stuff and them to
collaborate
on this I mean it's the Dream Team best
writers best creators honored to work
with them Taylor and I have crossed
paths many times in the past I've wanted
to jump on ship with them
um
Sylvester in this I've known Sylvester
since I was 18. walked into the trainers
uh Gunner Peterson's while prepping for
Troy and Sly was in there climbing the
ceiling rope up with his legs jacked up
you know scissored out he was always the
sweetest
um most supportive always asking what I
was up to but I was shooting how this
shoe went that shoe went and so to share
the screen with him in this is is felt
like it was due time it was fantastic
let's get out of here no I mean it's I
feel like honestly they could really
keep you know Terry Taylor they both
keep their ears to the streets to know
what the world wants to uh see what we
crave for somehow it always hits it's
like the the like uh the the uh it's
like the sage who always knows what the
uh the lottery number is going to be and
you go to them and get the secret life
or you know that the uh GameStop stock
market is gonna shut down so you
investor yeah it's you know it's uh it's
the predictability of it is is beyond
anything else
you're laughing at me man no it's uh I
don't know these analogies are
incredible look remember the last
interview with him you know comparing
the mobs and gangsters to female exotic
dancers but he makes it you like I try
to make it it's real though it's like
everything is connected right so you
know but I forget the the specific
question but speaking of everything
connected were there any jokes on set or
did anyone talk to Taylor or whatever
about so if we get to do multiple
Seasons what season do we get to cross
over with Yellowstone oh I'm rolling
that's uh that's for for us to know and
y'all to find out maybe right
that's how it goes yeah that's the one
I'm joking around but you know
um I know we know you joking how crazy
would that be though wow listen man I
mean Taylor Taylor's Taylor's really got
a gift but he does all the work like he
he's phenomenal even Glasser telling a
story last night about how this came to
fruition yeah I mean you know it was him
and Sly sitting down talking about
um um doing something like this you know
two days uh 40 minutes later Taylor
pitched David Glasser
um the story next morning pitch to have
the story uh uh ends uh two days later
he had the script the next day they took
it to the studio sold the idea like and
so
um that's just who Taylor is that's how
he works that's how he operates that's
why um
uh his material is irresistible to watch
it's got determination it's got grit
it's got brass
um and it's got a massive amount of
Integrity
um he's done a wonderful role and it's
just beginning and and I'm proud to be a
part of it I already got a wrap I'm just
going to say I really like that it can
be serious at times and other times can
be loose and fun it has a good tone
it's just uh it's just the old beginning
it's just getting started as well
on that note I gotta rap I'm just gonna
say congrats guys I know it's going to
be a big hit and a pleasure to see both
of you thank you I appreciate that